[Musique]
soumah propulsion nucléaire anglais sous
marins nucléaires dans son jean et sané
le avant sa dilution
je tenterai de vous être confirmée
embarquement demain à 4 heures vous êtes
l'assurance vie du pays une chance mon
garçon
c'est quoi un placard acoustique
c'est dangereux
pourquoi j'ai fait quelque chose dans
notre assaut du cateau il n'y a pas de
sous marins quatre balles
je sais le rendez vous est le nageur là
c'est oui ou c'est non
le pont de loup nous a détecté seconde
photo combattu diffusion doit récupérer
les nageurs c'est là mais ce sont les
trois points ce soir
j'ai toujours le champ du boult en audio
les poches pleines
je trouvais ce que c'est on est en
niveau d'alerté 6 grands champs vous
passez commandant de sous-marin
nucléaire lanceur d'engins le fleuron de
la marine nationale est pour vous vous
prenez l'effroyable gare de vous forcer
à passer commande du titane pour
commencer vous escorteraient le voyage
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient dilués dans la
mer gelée
ils ont la république vous commande
d'effectuer une frappe en riposte
nous avons été pris au piège c'est ma
vie à apprendre également à respecter
les procédures
à très fort et je ne traduis ces grains
c'est nos frères enfin cela c'est pas à
nos frères ce sont des marins se sort de
tir
la plus noire
gênant
[Musique]